let's jump into this first story
from newsweek
joe biden's new world order comment
jumped on by conspiracy theorists okay
let's just uh read a bit about what joe
biden said he said
as one of the top military people said
to me in a secure meeting the other day
okay can i just pause for a second oh my
gosh that is not what he said
no no it's right there
the top military people in the secure
meeting about the national the new world
writer
but but i also i'm just talking to
hunter i i want to point out the two
crazy things they're like
it's just it's a conspiracy theory and
biden literally prefaced this by saying
top military people in our secure
meeting said it but also why is biden
spilling secure meeting details to the
public like in a rambly i just imagine
that as he's talking there's like you
know kamala is just like
and then you've got like gensake and
they're going no no no no stop stop
anyway he said it's like we've discussed
the new ways to assassinate vladimir
putin uh personalized bio weapon you see
and you know he'll hillary was hey on
the shelf hillary was there and she said
can we just drone this guy oh my gosh
all right hold on here's let's hear this
quote here's what biden said as one of
the top military people said to me in a
secure meeting the other day
60 million people died between 1900 and
1946 and since then we've established a
liberal world order and that hadn't
happened in a long while a lot of people
dying but nowhere near the chaos and now
is a time when things are shifting
there's going to be a new world order
out there and we've got to lead it and
we've got to unite the rest of the free
world in doing it
they then go on to say several people
online took biden using the phrase new
world order to confirm the existence of
the aforementioned conspiracy theory
here's what they do here's what the
media is doing
powerful world leaders like clinton
george h.w bush even hillary clinton
they've all said there will be a new
world order
now for most people they think that
means there's going to be a global
system a judicial system or or legal
system because the council on foreign
relations publicly states that's what
their intention is with the liberal
world order they said after world war ii
to prevent war various you know powerful
institutions came together and creating
you know international organizations and
treaties to prevent this from ever
happening again and now there's going to
be a new version of that that's it
that's all it means so the media will
will push the most insane absurd version
of the conspiracy so they can try and
discredit what joe biden just outright
said that in a secure meeting he was
told this but but i think there's also
and and it's you know to go back to the
the headline of the show tonight
there's something even deeper that biden
is getting at because it's not just that
he's talking about setting up a new
version of the world order he's
essentially describing the fourth
turning so that means the president of
the united states just came out and said
that he was briefed by the top levels of
our military that we are in a fourth
turning is is that not what he just said
that's exactly look he didn't say
literally the fourth attorney but like
you're right that's essentially what
he's getting at right so you know the
only thing they're reading some strauss
howe and this he said four generations
that's that that's that's too much it's
obvious they're watching tim castle
yeah i think they actually some people
at the white house are because when we
were watching biden's campaign speech it
was a state of the union but he didn't
really get to say you know called a
campaign speech right um we were like
why are they so tight on biden and then
they they pulled out the camera no
i think they're watching and then they
point back in on his face thanks guys
well this is an administration that is
literally working right now on a global
minimum corporate tax right and so it's
not as though there's something very
literal happening when you say new world
order and that's why the conversation
about a new world order is immensely
frustrating because there's a literal
meaning to the term new world order that
has been explicit among global leaders
for forever and every once in a while
they slip up and say a buzzword that's
associated with conspiracy theories but
that's what's frustrating about the
dismissal of this as a conspiracy theory
is that like listen we have an imf we
have a world bank we have a united
nations we're working on a global
minimum tax right now this stuff is
pretty much out in the open and when you
have a slip from the president united
states like this even from an
administration that would avoid sort of
veering into that territory it's
extremely telling and it's not even as
though to the point about a fourth
turning that's not even in the abiding
consciousness he's just talking about
what his job is it was just to be
friends with boris johnson and angela
merkel and all these people and to to
have the have control at their
fingertips well i think
i think i do think it's both though
because he talks about the 60 million
dying and that it's this cycle that
happens every three to four gen so the
preface of it is where he's talking
about the fourth turning and that this
leads to setting up a new version of
that someone i always have to say rules
based orders they don't say new world
order who wants to read what website
that is what organizations
can you pull up the article yeah here we
go so uh it's from the world economic
forum who wants to read the title
136 countries have agreed to a global
minimum tax rate here's what it means
that's great okay jack i like that so
this the world economic forum is citing
reuters but clearly you know the reason
i pulled this up is the world economic
forum is very much interested in a lot
of this
global policy new world order stuff
the council on foreign you know what let
me let me do this let me let me uh well
let's read a little bit here
you see the countries behind the global
minimum tax rate together account for
over 90 percent of the global economy so
that is to say
90 percent of the global economy are
agreeing to a global corporate minimum
tax rate which means they're agreeing to
the infrastructure to support and
enforce a global a global minimum tax
rate so it's not just that you can make
this argument that like listen if we
were all on an even playing field things
would make more sense economically no
they're creating an infrastructure to
enforce a global minimum tax rate right
now check this out this is the council
on foreign relations website news guard
certified 100 out of 100
is it a conspiracy theory when the
council on foreign relations says what
is the liberal world order and they
literally say world leaders created a
series of international organizations
and agreements to promote global
cooperation on issues including security
trade health and monetary policy the us
has championed this system known as the
liberal world order for the past 75
years during this time the world has
enjoyed unprecedented peace and
prosperity i just gotta pause real quick
especially the troops in vietnam
uh korea
that was also very peaceful the bombing
of belgrade kicking the doors in iraq
was very peaceful for those rwanda
peaceful rwanda
you know you know what you know what it
is they're
man it's it's it's very gensakyan it's
like
they're bragging about the thing they've
done but it's been an unmitigated
failure across the board but also it
doesn't exist right right
no
no no no
we've created
so michael michael anton actually has a
great
formulation for what this is and he
calls it the celebration parallax and so
the celebration parallax means when they
talk about it it is good and laudatory
but if anyone mentions it in a critical
sense not only are they wrong but also
the thing they're discussing doesn't
exist right uh the new world
new world order is
amazing and just so great and i'm really
excited for klaus schwab and yeah all
that stuff feels like now he's not can't
wait to not own anything because i'm
going to be so happy
but this is what's interesting is that
we lose and i wrote about this recently
that we have this nuclear order and
nuclear technology is literally younger
than some people walking this earth and
it is the most dramatic technological
advancement that has ever happened in
the history of humanity and it's
happened over the course of people's
lifetimes like it has happened that
quickly and we take for granted how
dramatically it changed the way that we
operate and so the new world order is
actually really new it's really new and
it's something that like when you have
all this technology at your fingertips
of course the leaders of the united
states of course the leaders of all of
these different countries are going to
want to have the power concentrated at
their fingertips because it's so
powerful and because they want they have
this sort of technological ability to do
it now that they can concentrate power
and rule over everyone because they're
terrified of what would happen if they
didn't what i'm wondering is are the
governments making concessions with
these corporations like they're like the
writings on the wall the corporations
are taking over let's just intercede
with them instead of try and resist like
you said that they're all working
together to create a global tax rate
like is that
i i wonder if it's just like the
governments have given up and they're
like hey corporations are coming
schwab's right corporate governments i
totally think so i think they're the
same i mean trump's first secretary of
state was rex tillerson like he was like
literally the ceo of exxon
and people it's like mind-boggling to me
that people forget that but it i think
they're basically the same at this point
i'd like to point out that uh the
council on foreign relations
basically describes the new world order
conspiracy theory as something that's
already happened
that that's the that's the weird thing
for 75 years for 75 years there has been
a liberal world economic order where a
liberal world order where world leaders
created a series of international
organizations and agreements to promote
global cooperation including security
trade health and monetary policy i said
it fast there you go anyway the point is
now that biden is like
every three to four generations
something changes basically saying we're
in the fourth turning and there's going
to be a new world order no longer the
liberal world order there'll be a new
world order well
i don't understand why they're acting
like it's not a real thing but it's also
it what we are actually seeing and the
question is will we will this trigger a
thucydides trap right um because and i
believe it's the economist that came out
and dubbed what we're starting to see
the
just the sort of edges of right now are
or is an alternative world order and
this is the idea that because the us is
sanctioning russia so hard because the
u.s is now sanctioning ccp officials um
they've threatened sanctions on india
well guess what you put those three
countries together that's over half the
world's population so they are going to
find a way to work together outside of
you and they're going to build their own
order in order to do so so the saudis of
course are already selling oil in
in the yuan so they're getting away from
the petrodollar you might see a rise
they're already doing it they're
discussing it right right um you're also
seeing uh india and russia are already
starting to trade in between their own
currencies they're not using u.s dollars
so that's the point of all of this is
because all of these transactions are
done at least certainly for oil and and
energy at large are done in u.s backed
currency so that's the swift system so
the idea that the us dollar is just fiat
is actually i'm sorry crypto bros it's
not 100 correct because the us dollar is
essentially backed by something and
that's oil because of this artificial
demand for us dollars because of foreign
countries always needing to convert into
the us dollar that props it up so it's
not necessarily gold backed it's sort of
oil backed by this
global
trouble
but
look i mean nothing's stopping any one
of these countries uh or world leaders
from switching off of the us dollar
right like nationalism is terrible it is
intentionally conflated with white
nationalism unless it's ukrainians
fighting putin and then everyone that's
sort of in the neoliberal establishment
loves nationalism and celebrates it and
we see stories in the media on cnn of
these ukraine patriots who are you know
just carrying the banner of nationalism
which these same people think is so icky
here because it's about they see
themselves as citizens of the world um
and especially that's especially true of
the people like that doesn't mean you
can't be american but you see yourself
as a global citizen right they have
something literally called the global
citizen festival before your nationality
but you watch how quickly that flips
when the nationalists are in support of
of their agenda right so cnn will you
know argue that somebody should be fired
from their job because they're cracking
their knuckles and it accidentally looks
like an okay symbol but an actual
commander of the azov battalion was just
on cnn yesterday who are an avowed um
far-right neo-nazi replete unit within
the u.s or within the ukrainian military
who was it who was
straightening their jacket before an
interview stephen miller stephen miller
yeah and they said it was a double
double white power these people are
insane i can't imagine i don't
understand how anybody the same people
right to emily's point the same people
who will see nazis everywhere behind
every shadow here in the united states
when they're faced with an actual group
of avowed neo-nazis the boy who cries
we'll say oh no no no no no those people
they're fine because they're fighting
for something that we need to fight i
was researching the azov and i look back
it looks like the germans after world
war one took ukraine as like a
protectorate and then a bunch of uh
germans were there and then when world
war ii broke out a bunch of nazis were
there in western ukraine and started
like got really vicious and uh started
up as of i don't know much about it but
this is where i got to from there this
is why there's germans why they were
nazis in western ukraine is because it
was hold over from the wars
it's not so much that it's not so much
that it was a whole i mean
i think you have a half of it right it's
it's this idea and it wasn't as off
battalion back then it was this guy
stepped on bandera who yeah
who so banderites and banderism um was a
arose because of this now it started off
as being an anti-soviet movement and a
pro-ukrainian nationalism movement kind
of like you were talking about but then
it went completely extreme very quickly
and even before the germans arrived in
world war ii they were essentially
declaring themselves on the side of the
germans because they were so anti-soviet
union so they start slaughtering
russians they start slaughtering poles
jews um if you basically if you were in
that area of western ukraine it's known
as west galasia or um excuse me east
galatia that you were basically not
ukrainian you were just completely wiped
out by this guy bandera
but the previous president of ukraine
just recently actually named him as a
hero of ukraine and a hero of the nation
there's there's statues to this guy that
are up in their in their city squares
they must be torn to the ground
there was a there was a photo of one of
the azov guys with the black sun i think
it was was edited
yeah right he was wearing like a uh ever
you see them everywhere i think it was
there was a reuters article where they
had someone who had the patch on and
they had to they actually blurted out
wow oh that's the ss symbol on the shot
himmler himmler did that it's not a good
black song this is for i hadn't read
about it yet i know the symbol though
you know
we got a weird
whatever is going on in this country
where there are shows like this where
we're able to point out that ukraine has
staunch nationalists and you know overt
neo-nazi uh ideology yet the mainstream
media is cheering for it the antifa left
is now profile i guess you know pro
fascist i mean it is so incredibly
offensive because they have no idea
what they've done to the they actually
don't understand the fear that they've
instilled in normal working-class people
who for instance really like donald
trump and are afraid that they're going
to be called a nazi a literal nazi by
people at their office place by the
human resources department for tweeting
something in support of trump or
facebooking someone something in support
of trump and so it is just like to see
this it is so incredibly offensive
because they spent years seeing seeing
nazis everywhere i i have a question
though what would happen if
you if someone made black sun buttons
like pins but it was yellow and blue
like the ukrainian flag oh and it said
as of you know on the top you can see
that kleenox box is yellow oh yeah look
at that but do you think do you think
these leftists would wear that yeah if
you told them like someone's a pro
ukrainian symbol
yeah they'd walk around wearing actual
actual nazi symbols oh yeah they
wouldn't care that'd be a good um that'd
be good like ryan long uh you know
segment to do it comes down to emotion
in that situation like are they familiar
with the symbol and does it strike an
emotional chord if it does they'll stay
away from it but if they don't know
they'll they'll go out hold on like so
let me ask you a couple of different
scenarios let's say you go to union
square in new york city and you have
these pins and you walk up to someone
say hey would you wear this in support
of the the the you know freedom fighters
in ukraine the as of battalion it's
ukrainian flag they'll probably say yes
right
now what if you said would you wear this
in support of the azov battalion it's
the ukrainian flag and the nazis black
sun this is their symbol do you think
they would wear it then
yeah i still think they would if you
said it was the nazi black stone
you think they would still do it i think
i think they would get a short circuit
but
it doesn't process right what's even
more interesting to me though is that
you know you go up to people who have
never heard of ukraine have never heard
of belarus you know maybe other than in
some like abstract discussion probably
can't find it on a map and yet are now
suddenly these
experts on it and also it becomes their
entire identity just overnight the same
people who were you know vaccine experts
a couple of weeks before
and prior to that they were
epidemiologists and before that they
were racism experts throughout all 20
and historians yeah and now they're and
now they're military members who are
saying you know these ridiculous
comments like oh you should just run up
and throw paint at the tank and that'll
you know that'll stop them and that
you're you know throw some water
balloons at it with you know filled with
paint my personal favorite crazy
craziness was when uh zielinski held up
the red salute and i said i didn't know
if he was supporting black lives matter
or communism it was meant to be like
tongue-in-cheek and then i got a bunch
of responses where they're like you
wouldn't have you you're a coward you
don't have the balls to go to ukraine
and i was just like you know cause i've
been there three times like well you
were there in the original coup i was
there i was yeah i was there in the the
start of the euro my dan protest for
several months and then i went back you
know a couple years later and you know
sort of followed up and did a little
video and stuff so yeah i was actually
there and i had you know guys around me
screaming at me and i was like american
journalist and they're like oh yeah
you're cool now come on in dude it was
crazy we got to go inside a government
building that ransacked they'd like
stripped all the paperwork and pulled it
all out it was nuts crazy times man i
wasn't there when they when they started
throwing the fire bombs though what city
were you in thousand camp
yeah this is the you know the
independent square they call it or
whatever euro maidan that's my dance
square square but they were calling it
euro maidan because they all wanted to
be in the eu
and the crazy thing is we went to a pro
yanakovich rally where everyone's waving
these flags and it was being reported in
british press as like so yanukovych just
for people who don't know yanukovych was
the current president at this time who
essentially blew up this economic
package for the eu
that a lot of people wanted him to sign
you know they wanted to sign this please
do this who hired tony podesta
to massage their messaging uh in the
senate with hillary clinton's state
department yanukovych yes yes yes so and
they set it up through something called
the center for a modern uh the european
center for a modern ukraine to try and
get around feral laws because it looked
like they were just working for this
neutral think tank is the most like
beautifully corrupt it's just right and
they're all the payments we're like
going through cyprus and yeah yeah wow
so yeah so it so ukrainians get all mad
and very upset about this at least in
places like
kiev so they launched this massive
protest turns very violent but you also
had ukrainians who were still supporting
yanukovych and he had been at the time
the
democratically elected president of the
country so you did have these dueling
these dueling protests in the background
just to clear that up yanukovych was was
working with tony he hired tony podesta
yeah so he had a lobbying operation in
the united states that included paul
manafort who's working for mercury at
the time and tony podesta's podesta
group which is now defunct which is
amazing because it was one of the
biggest lobbying firms in dc one of the
most powerful lobbying firms in dc yeah
and it went corrupt i mean it went uh
defunct over this corruption because it
came out he was a casualty of the war
against trump the medias were against
trump um because they obviously caught
paul manafort on this and he was
convicted of violating feral law but it
was amazing you can look at the lobbying
records of tony podesta's firm meeting
with people in hillary clinton's state
department as a representative for the
european center for modern ukraine which
he later admitted
he knew
was basically being was a front for
yanukovych so yanukovych wanted to join
the americans or was he a rush i thought
he's a russian puppet well that's what
and jack could probably explain this
better but that goes
that has happened in different ways
depending on the time so if it's before
the eu the collapse of the eu deal it's
a different than if it was after what i
was told uh of course but since we're
talking about that you have to point out
mueller goes after manafort who had been
trump's campaign manager trump has to
fire manafort after all of this comes
out in like march of 16 or so um i mean
maybe later than that um they have this
thing called the black ledger which
turns out to be fake but supposedly by
made by um ukrainian operatives but
ended up you know they said it was the
like illegal payments to manafort but
throughout all of this manafort had been
doing it through the podesta group
podesta and tony podesta were given
immunity during all of this but manafort
has to go down for it interesting
i was told by some of the activists that
their view at least a lot of the
students and a lot of protesters was
that yanukovych was playing both sides
that he would you know well clearly
right so he was trying to get these
deals these sweet you know deals from
the from the west and then he would go
to russia and be like oh look what
they're going to do for us and so people
were like the protesters wanted to be
part of the eu
being a part of the eu
this is their their perspective
we could move to poland we could move to
the uk get jobs the economy is going to
immediately improve our lives will
immediately improve and that's one of
the reasons the eu is like hold on there
hold on there we'll figure it out but
the concern was ukraine's economy was
too weak
a lot of them were scared they had also
the levels of corruption yeah right you
need to meet certain wickets and certain
bars before you can gain entry to the eu
and truth be told that's what biden said
biden was saying you know corruption was
a big deal we were trying to weed out
the corruption it's just funny because i
don't trust him because he is corrupt i
gotta know for
when you start peeling back the layers
of the russia collusion hoax and you
find at the bottom here that tony
podesta is the brother of john podesta
hillary clinton's campaign chairman and
was taking money from yanukovych who you
you know
playing both sides i think is a fair way
to say it and fled to russia by the way
after the collapse of that deal
and was protected by putin's government
when you peel back to that layer you
realize what [ __ ] this is
yanukovych hired tony podesta who was
running podesta group at the time yep
exactly and so he hired podesta he hired
manafort because that's how lobbying
works in dc um they need to have a
republican and a democrat basically to
get what they want done so that they can
massage both the republicans and the
democrats and it's a that's why i always
use this example of one of the it so
perfectly crystallizes corruption in dc
so if the if yanukovych was working with
the americans and the podesta group to
become with this american style thing
then why would podesta flee to russia no
uh
oh okay i thought you said tony podesta
did no yanukovych got it no i don't know
where tony podesta is i think he's in
new york city i could be wrong about
that i think didn't he live with uh
abramovich that woman weren't they like
friends
oh really cooking that like blood
cooking thing there's weird people she
did she did that famous uh the artist is
present do you ever see that i actually
saw it in person oh really
because i was visiting real real quick
though for those i don't know
she just sat in a room for like 30 days
is that what it was no it's like the
lobby of
the museum of moderate
and on like like the second floor lobby
but i was going at the time because they
had the tim burton exhibit um that was
only going to be there for a little bit
and it was sort of so tim burton opened
up his archives and you know everything
from edward scissorhands to beetlejuice
to like the batman costume the joker's
stuff um the
nightmare before christmas all the
little jack skellington heads and
everything and i was like oh that's
great tim burton let's you know we were
in new york i said we got to check this
out because it was only there for a
limited time
they had like a sand worm from
beetlejuice coming out of the ceiling it
was awesome but as we're going up we see
this this woman in all all red this red
dress just sitting in a chair and
there's this sort of roped area around
it and everybody's looking at her and
and you know
this is probably like maybe 2010 or so
and
you know i'm looking at it i was like
what's you know what's with the lady in
the in the chair why are people looking
at this oh no it's high art right
you're not sending their best
is she going to be drawing something
does she do caricatures like the people
on the street or something let me tell
you it's just this let me tell you
what's disconcerting what's
disconcerting to me is that
people would come in and you could wait
in line to sit down in a chair like in
front of her right and there were people
who would like sit down and just jay-z
they'd start crying they would just
start like start crying and it's i'm
just like why are you crying you know
just
people i don't know man
i really wonder sometimes but a lot of
people well i'm just going to say it
again for the 800th time in the past
week every day we get a new story that's
a hoax there's a uh uh we got the
supreme court hearings going on for um
what's her name kentucky jackson yeah
yeah and uh someone tweeted
let me just remind everybody that
christine blasey ford credibly accused
brett kavanaugh and republicans didn't
care and i just see that and i'm just
like dude you guys you lie about
basically every major political story
non-stop all day every day and then a
month goes by and it gets debunked so no
i'm just you could come out and you know
point at the sky and say there's a giant
meteor i'm i'm not looking up just like
the movie like this no no no you're not
going to give me it's it's the easiest
motion in the world to look up i won't
do it screw you you guys are liars i'll
give you an example today is the
three-year anniversary of three years
it's been of the mueller report coming
out and that press conference that he
gave
completely debunking the trump russia
collusion hoax wow three years since the
debunking of the hoax is today wow and
yet you go to anybody on the left or
your your casual cnn msnbc viewer they
all believe it 100 well they're bringing
it back i mean it's it's it's having
actually a revival which is really
interesting you're seeing a lot more
people on the left continuing to talk
about it now because it's their
deflection point when they talk about
the biden administration's handling of
ukraine they're like well donald trump
was in bed with putin
you're so you we've been doing this for
years and you still haven't understood
you still haven't reckoned with some
disaster that that happened so yeah that
so it doesn't matter nothing persuades
them otherwise they meant to solidify
this sort of
you know government takeover that they
were pushing in ukraine bringing them
into the nato fold bringing them into
the security blanket
during the hillary clinton
administration right but of course the
hillary clinton administration never
took place and so they needed this
placeholder to sort of keep that going
keep that energy going for throughout
the four years of trump and then that
became the trump-russia collusion hoax
then finally after 2020 which is
essentially the same kind of domestic
color revolution that we were just
talking about the color revolution of
maidan
you see those exact same
tactics being used here in the united
states right down to the violent riots
in cities
and then now that it then when it ended
suddenly ukraine and victoria nuland the
same exact person who was behind so much
of that in 2013 2014 comes right back in
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 00 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm and we'll see you all
there
you